Speaker 1: The last 48 hours have been some of the
most overtly anti-Semitic in the American media
space than I can remember in a very long time. A
little bit later, we're going to get to one of the
most insane anti-Semitic rants I've seen short
of actual Nazis. And it came from Kanye West.
That's after. But first, we have to talk about
failed former President Donald Trump seemingly
cracking in an authoritarian, fascistic tirade
against Jews, not only attacking American Jews,
but warning American Jews. You'd better appreciate
what I've done for you. Ah, things could get very
bad. A typical anti-Semitic, fascistic tirade,
which I'm going to explain to you. Donald Trump
went on his platform. Troth sent Schultz known
to some as truth social. And Donald Trump said
the following over the weekend, and I do, quote,
No president has done more for Israel than I have.
Somewhat surprisingly, however, our wonderful
evangelicals are far more appreciative of this
than the people of the Jewish faith, especially
those living in the U.S.. Those living in Israel,
though, are a different story. Highest approval
rating in the world, by the way. That, true, could
easily be prime minister. U.S. Jews have to get
their act together and appreciate what they have
in Israel. And here's the warning before it is too
late. This is truly disgusting. Disgusting. Now,
first, before we get into explaining the layers
of anti-Semitism here, just a sort of reality.
The Evangelical love for Israel and thus
support for Republican presidents on that issue.
Has nothing to do with Judaism and it has nothing
to do with Jews. The evangelical love for Israel
relates primarily to their biblical belief that if
they support Israel, it will accelerate the second
coming of Jesus Christ. And implicit in that,
depending on which version of Christianity you
believe or follow, there is a rapture apocalypse.
The Jews eventually do die in some versions of the
story. All the Jews other than 144,000 of them
die. It's bonkers. And so you should judge the
evangelical support for Israel as an example of
complete and utter religious insanity. It has
nothing to do with what Jews like me actually
care about or are concerned with. That's number
one. Okay. Now, what Donald Trump says here is
sadly a classic from the anti-Semitic tropes
of history. Why aren't Jews more grateful to me
for something I did for them? That is a classic,
classic anti-Semitic trope. When Jews don't
accept the leaders cult or the cult leader,
whichever way you want to say it. They are seen as
implicitly undermining the leader and they are bad
and maybe they even need to be punished for that.
Then there's also the horribly anti-Semitic idea
of the good Jews versus the bad ones out in the
diaspora. When we talk about the Jewish diaspora,
we mean Jews around the world. And I know a lot
of this stuff is new to some in our audience
and and maybe unfamiliar, but that's why we're
talking about it. This is a classic. There's a
classic. Here are the good Jews, right? The ones
either staying within their shtetls or ghettos
or whatever. And then sometimes if it's right
wingers, the good Jews in Israel and then the
bad Jews of the diaspora, those bad liberal Jews
in the United States and the UK and France and
on and on and on. And then, of course, there's
also the threat there. That's the other part
of it. Get your act together because, you know,
people have come after Jews in the past. Things
have gotten pretty bad for Jews historically
in the past. You'd better get your act together
and appreciate Trump before it is too late and bad
things start to happen. If you don't appreciate me
now, once you get beyond the anti-Semitism, you
also realize that Trump, as well as many others,
have absolutely no understanding of the reality
of Jews in the United States as a community
with interests and priorities that are very
different than those of Jews living in Israel,
for example. And this goes back to the dual
loyalty antisemitic trope. There's this idea that,
okay, listen, if you if your parents or
grandparents came to the U.S. from Italy
or from Germany or from Portugal, there is not
this thing that follows you around about you might
still have loyalty to Portugal if it came down
to it. Do you choose the U.S.? Or do you choose
Portugal or whatever the case may be? And with
Jews, even Jews who have never been to Israel,
there is this idea of dual loyalty. Well, I don't
know. Here is what's good for the U.S. and here's
maybe what's good for Israel. And these American
Jews can't really be trusted because they they
have a loyalty to Israel that might override. Most
Jews have never even been to Israel. Don't even
follow the politics of Israel, internal or foreign
policy. Understand that anti-Semitism, while
proclaiming that you love Israel, is a standard
of the evangelical right and it's definitely
a standard of MAGA. So a disgusting comment
from Trump, but nothing compared to Kanye West